welcome to the soul forum a monthly
debate series that features topics of
special interest to libertarians and
aims to enhance social and professional
ties within New York City's libertarian
community we're partnered with Reason
magazine in presenting these debates and
you can catch audio of all our events on
the recent podcast which you'll find in
the iTunes Store thanks also to the
Smith Family Foundation for making this
series possible I'm Jean Epstein
economics and books editor at Barron's
financial weekly and the solo forum
director and moderator for more
information and to buy tickets to our
future debates go to our website at V
solo forum org this is an Oxford style
debate in which the audience initially
votes for against or undecided on the
resolution and then again after the
debate is over whoever moves that vote
in his favor is declared the winner
tonight's resolution is as follows the
US government should offer a Medicare
like plan that would be available to all
Americans buying health insurance Kate
to chair Bo we are now closing the
voting okay okay
she's got all the votes initially
defending the resolution we have Paul
Starr of Princeton University author of
the social transformation of American
medicine Paul please come to the stage
arguing for the negative we have David
gold he'll offer author of catastrophic
care David please come to the stage
[Applause]
[Music]
now ball star you have 12 minutes to
defend the resolution the US government
should offer a Medicare like plan that
would be available to all Americans
buying health insurance taken away poll
okay well thank you very much for
inviting me to speak in favor of the
idea of providing Medicare a Medicare
like plan as an option for people buying
health insurance now first let me make
three points about Medicare one among
Americans with all types of insurance
those on Medicare are the most satisfied
with their coverage Medicare is in the
United States the most popular form of
coverage the second Medicare has done a
far better job of controlling health
care costs than as the non Medicare
private insurance market and third while
in general Americans are not as healthy
as citizens of the other wealthy
democracies Americans 65 years of age
and over do better on health indicators
than others their age in pure countries
so Medicare is more popular and a slower
go through costs and the people who
depend on it are on average healthier
than their counterparts in many peer
countries all of these I believe good
reasons why we ought to make Medicare
and Medicare like plan available to
other Americans as an option now I am
NOT suggesting Medicare is perfect as it
is there are ways to improve it to get a
bad better value for money and some
important tests of alternatives are
currently underway within Medicare I'm
also not suggesting Medicare would need
no adjustments for people under age 65
and I'm also not saying that the
development of a Medicare option could
be done overnight it ought to be done
stages assessing the results as we go
along what I'd like to do this evening
in mind 12 minutes is outline a couple
of concrete steps we could take in that
direction and the reasons they make
sense but first I want to make several
clarifications first we're not debating
single-payer this evening my Medicare
like option otherwise known as a public
option is not the same a single-payer as
soon as you say option as soon as you
refer to making a plan available as this
resolution does you're not talking about
reducing all healthcare finance to a
single payer second let's understand how
Medicare works Medicare gives seniors a
choice between the traditional public
Medicare plan and private so-called
Medicare Advantage plans so if we could
strip away ideological blinders we could
see that Medicare itself is a
marketplace it has multiple plans
varying in structure and to a lesser
extent and benefits Medicare however is
different from the marketplaces created
under the Affordable Care Act for people
under age 65 who purchase insurance
individually Medicare is different
because it has a public option a public
plan chosen by about two-thirds of
seniors a plan that actually gives them
a much wider choice of doctors and
hospitals than most Americans have these
days and the Medicare program as a whole
does a good job controlling costs
because the public plan sets prices for
providers that's the private plans can
shadow price that is they tend to follow
Medicare's lead so the advantage of
Medicare's price discipline spill over
into the private Medicare market third
we're not even talking this evening at
least as I understand it about Medicare
for all the debate tonight is about
making a Medicare like plan available to
other Americans who buy insurance and
I'm going to interpret the resolution as
being in the first instance specifically
about Americans who need to pay for
health
you need to obtain health insurance on
their own that is who don't have an
employer provided plan or coverage
through the military or the veteran's
health care system or or any other
system and the problems with our health
insurance system have long been most
acute for people who buy insurance
individually or through small businesses
and who don't qualify for Medicaid the
VA or any other program they're the
people who the health insurance
marketplaces and affordability subsidies
in the ACA were designed to help but
there continue to be problems in those
markets problems aggravated by the Trump
administration's war of attrition
against the bomb Obamacare problems that
will be aggravated even more if Congress
repeals the ACA and puts us back in the
world where people with pre-existing
conditions can't get coverage and one of
the core problems perhaps the most
important problem in the individual
insurance market is the lack of
competition in many parts of the country
in many of those areas these are mostly
in rural areas and in the south there is
only one insurer and a few cases there
temporarily been no insurers now the
Trump administration has aggravated that
problem by creating uncertainty in the
insurance market uncertainty because of
its uncertainty about enforcing the law
or about fulfilling certain obligations
under the law to them to insurance
companies that are legally obligated to
provide certain kinds of subsidies and
as a result of that the Congressional
Budget Office has projected an increase
of two million people and the number of
uninsured for this coming year after the
ACA cut the proportion of uninsured in
the United States from 16 percent in
2010 to 8.8% in 2016 now from the
beginning the ACA should have had a
fallback provision for a public option
to guarantee adequate competition in
those areas where the market failed to
respond and that kind of provision is
more necessary now clearly necessary now
so here's the first concrete proposal
that I've made together with Jacob
hacker who was supposed to be here this
evening
this can be found at the website of the
journal Health Affairs wherever there
are two or fewer options that is in
these specific marketplaces for
individuals Congress would introduce
Medicare into those marketplaces now in
other words not only with the public
Medicare would public Medicare offer a
plan
we'd also require insurers who already
compete in a region's Medicare Advantage
market also to offer a plan in the ACA
marketplace so it's basically linking
the Medicare marketplace to the ACA
marketplace and it boosts competition in
a way particularly advantageous to
enrollees unlike most of the I'm sorry -
you had a is that five minutes so that's
all right unlike most of the narrow
Network private plans in the ACA
marketplaces Medicare offers a wide
choice of providers because nearly all
hospitals and doctors take Medicare and
that broad choice is one of the reasons
for the high level of satisfaction with
Medicare building on Medicare and
Medicare Advantage will give people in
the individual and small group market
more choice and help create competition
where it's faltered now the second idea
that I've offered for expanding access
to Medicare is what I've called midlife
Medicare and it would enable people ages
50 to 64 who have not been offered an
employer plan and they're not eligible
for any other coverage to buy into
Medicare and as in senior Medicare the
beneficiaries of midlife Medicare would
need to pay premiums well the Congress
would subsidize midlife Medicare to the
same extent it subsidizes
employer-provided coverage compensating
also for the effects of adverse
collection an adverse selection adverse
selection is the tendency of only for
relatively sick people to enroll when
they are not obligated to just as the
Republican bill in the house would have
created a patient stabilization fund to
cover high-risk individuals now I make
these proposals in the spirit of
incremental change as I see it
introducing Medicare
to the ACA marketplaces would resolve
many of the immediate problems that you
read about in the press
midlife Medicare would pull out of those
marketplaces a relatively costly older
adult population were these reducing
premiums for the under 58 population now
if Republicans repeal the ACA as seems a
distinct possibility again this week the
case for midlife Medicare would be even
stronger because it's that older adult
group 50 to 64 that will be hit the
hardest by the loss of the subsidies and
the increase in private insurance
premiums that would follow if we were to
pass midlife medicare the question of
making a Medicare like plan available to
younger people that is people under age
50 that is people without employer
coverage would also an hour arise and I
could imagine again some incremental
extension of this idea of making
Medicare available to younger ages but
again this is not the same as
single-payer this really involves trying
to fill in of one of the problems in the
existing health insurance market so
these ideas would not require turning
health care in America upside down but
they would advance the cause of
providing all Americans with good health
care it costs that a subject a stronger
discipline than we have historically had
and I see I have two minutes left but I
will cede those two minutes to David and
perhaps reclaim them in that second
[Applause]
this is not an exchange of minute system
David you cats just 12 minutes and this
the two minutes is gone David take it
away for the negative I'm sorry
12 minutes for the negative from David
gold he'll well thank you gene and thank
you everyone for coming tonight and Paul
it's a pleasure to share the stage with
you when truly an honor the social
transformation of American medicine is
the first book I ever read about health
care and frankly the first book anyone
should read about health care it's
extraordinary
I want to start with a story which I
think is against the rules four years
ago one of my best friend's father's
father was told that his aortic valve
was gonna fail at some point he needed a
valve replacement and the sooner the
better he consulted the cardiac surgeons
at five big New York hospitals and was
stunned by how aggressively they pursued
him he was a Medicare patient he was 83
years old part of the Medicare argument
is that Medicare pays price is so low
that hospitals lose money on patients he
didn't experience that in fact they
pursued him so aggressively that he was
interested in a less invasive procedure
that was part of a double-blind trial
that was being conducted at New York
hospitals and one of them said we have a
way of getting you in the procedure
regardless he had the valve replacement
roughly 90,000 Medicare patients a year
have a valve replacement
and according to Medicare it was a
perfectly successful operation he was
alive 30 days later and in fact it was
miraculous he had his valve replaced was
out of the hospital in four or five days
was walking around four months later he
was dead and the reason he was dead is
because at some point he banged
something for some part of his body on
something and he bled to death because
everybody who gets a valve operation has
to take anticoagulants now the reason
I'm telling this story is because it's
under
believably common the last time somebody
looked and it's about five years ago of
the two million bet and Medicare
beneficiaries who died in a given year
roughly seven hundred thousand had
surgery that year out of every five over
ninety who died in a given year
one has surgery there's almost no
surgery recommended for somebody over
ninety because the risk/reward is
terrible it's very convenient for those
who care about politics to talk about
access to healthcare money how do we pay
for people to get health care as if it's
some black box some commodity well I'm
gonna dial eight to of the rules of
talking about health care tonight one is
I'm not going to pretend it's this black
box that we just buy I'm gonna pretend
something that we all know is true which
is how we pay for it
determines what we get and the second
thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
leave not often the island of healthcare
in which we tell ourselves that all that
matters is health care
there was a hilarious piece in The New
York Times talking to five health care
experts about which country the best
health care system and they all dissed
my favorite Singapore because not
transparent announced not this not that
Singapore spends four percent of GDP on
health care not a single one of these
economists said can you imagine all the
social good you can do if you save
fourteen percent of GDP
every conversation about health care is
how do we make sure everybody has all
the health care they need and in doing
so we have starved our population and
particularly our most needy of the other
things they need many of which are more
important
Medicare drives a certain type of care
it may be popular but here's what it
really is it's excessive its treatment
biased it's tons and tons of operations
and it's no general practitioners there
are 7,000 geriatricians left in the
country and eventually there will be
zero so as a result if you are over 75
there's a 50% chance you're on five
drugs there's a 50% chance if you are
that at least two of those drugs are
contraindicated you shouldn't be taken
both this is a totally unregulated out
of control system whose biggest
beneficiary is the healthcare industry
and the people who should be most aware
of that or at least aware of it because
they're so busy arguing for more health
care and more access and all the rest
that they don't realize the system we
built now my interest in healthcare
began with my father's death from the
medical accident so according to Johns
Hopkins Medical accidents are now the
third leading cause of death in the
United States 250,000 a year most of
them are in hospitals almost all of them
are among Medicare beneficiaries now
it's never listed as a cause of death
almost no States a medical error so
you're not aware of it but it's 250,000
people a year which means in the 20
years since Bill Clinton proposed health
care reform we've probably lost two and
a half million Americans I'm sorry for
half a million Americans to errors
committed while Medicare was their payer
and we could say hey it's all a matter
of money but I just can't believe that
now one of the key things that we need
to understand about Medicare is it
illusions and the biggest illusion is
that it's cheap how something that has
gone from 1 billion in spending to 675
billion in spending than two and a half
generations is called cheap I have no
idea but in understanding how a public
option will work and the incentives it
will give to our health care system it's
important to understand what Medicare
costs she first of all the biggest thing
is costs almost nothing to administer
almost everybody who writes in favor of
a public option or medicare for all says
private health insurers spend 15% of
benefits on just administration Medicare
spends 2% that's got to be cheap some
sound wrong with that well here's a hint
private insurers do Medicare's
administration for it as subcontractors
have you ever heard of somebody who will
pay somebody a housekeeper who will take
less for cleaning other people's houses
then he'll pay for having someone clean
their own house that's what you're
inclined to believe that some care
health insurers are doing administration
for Medicare less than they do it with
their own money what's really going on
well private insurers say no to things
they judge appropriateness they judge
safety they judge quality Medicare's
mandate is to say yes to everything and
of course the great irony is so it cost
thirteen and a half billion dollars to
administer Medicare six hundred and
seventy five billion dollars but
Medicare says it has roughly seventy
billion dollars of fraud every year now
here's the great thing about government
accounting that seventy billion of fraud
they don't count as an expense they
counted as benefits paid so you know if
the seventy billion of fraud by the way
completely eliminates their
administrative advantage in cost what
they say is cheaper but we gotta
remember Medicare is a political program
its constituency is politicians or
policy analysts not business people if
you've run a business you understand
what's going on Medicare is a bank
without security guards it's the
nonprofit model look how much money we
pay out how little it costs us to do it
underlying that and and by the way a
bank could run without security guards
but unlike Medicare it couldn't tell its
board of directors you know the money
stolen counts as revenue the second
element of Medicare supposed cheapness
though is the most important one which
is Medicare pays hospitals and doctors
less than private insurance well if
you've been in business you recognize
the make it up in volume fallacy problem
there again who's the constituency
politicians policy analysts academics
who cares what price you pay a hospital
if you let the hospital bundle as many
different diagnoses as possible when we
look at how Medicare has grown in cost
and where that cost goes
to argue it's cheap is absurd using med
packs onwards I love this rapid volume
growth may be a sign that Sun services
in the fee schedule for physicians and
other health professionals are mispriced
in other words we pay them so little
they do more of a mothership and that is
the story of Medicare now why is it like
this
well the reason it's like this is
because Medicare was based on a very
dishonest statement to us and to
providers to us Medicare says something
that no other country on earth has ever
said we're an entitlement we will pay
for all the health care you need how did
the industry respond to that I endlessly
increasing the definition of need it's
so obvious that you'd have to be you'd
never have to work in a business to do
that Medicare is dominated by special
interests there's seventeen medical C
trade associations whose CEOs earned
between one and five million dollars a
year it's not to convince Medicare to be
more efficient the health industry spent
five hundred million dollars a year on
lobbying our hospitals operate at sixty
five percent capacity twenty percent
less than the rest the world they stay
in business because Medicare keeps them
afloat we have so few geriatricians
because the specialists run the
price-setting mechanism so really
understanding how Medicare works makes
you rethink what's a public option what
is a public option it's an option that
sounds like you know what could be bad
about an option except it's nonsense the
people who originally proposed a public
option admitted years ago that what they
were really trying to do was get to
single-payer we see how difficult it is
for insurers to price the type of
customers that Professor Starr was
talking about try to imagine the
government saying you can take this
option here's the price how do we set
that price
there's no idea now what Medicare
supporters and public options for says
oh we'll set it in competition with
insurers but remember what Medicare
us right it allows large amounts of
fraud it never says no no insurer can
compete with that public option
advocates like to say the nice thing
about Medicare is our competitors it
doesn't need to make a profit that's not
what makes Medicare a competitor it's
that it doesn't care about losses this
year general revenues your tax money
will subsidize Medicare the tune of
three hundred and twenty billion dollars
the price of a public option will be
whatever Medicare wants it to be and
when politicians want single-payer it'll
be so low that a private insurer can't
compete and if it's too high by the way
we'll just have a high risk pool it'll
be extraordinaire expense what Medicare
hasn't proven and I mean real Medicare
not to pretend though I wish it were
better how we could improve it it's 51
years old as a man in my 50s we don't
approve it is what it is and what it is
is the core feature driving the
undisciplined supply pricing and
utilization of care that is so
undermined the social welfare of the
average American citizen
[Applause]
mon-star you have five minutes of
rebuttal take it away Paul so we
actually have a Medicare program that
involves private insurers although you
might never know it from the description
that David gave we have a working
marketplace in Medicare he presented it
as if the idea of a public option was
just a kind of insidious way of
introducing a single nationalized
insurance plan but actually private
insurers have done very well in Medicare
I mentioned that about one-third of
Medicare beneficiaries choose a private
plan actually among new beneficiaries
it's about one-half so it it is so it is
a working model it doesn't the fact that
we have a public Medicare plan doesn't
make it impossible for private insurers
to compete they do compete and that same
kind of model can be applied to the
population under age 65 now I want to
come to a number of the points that
David met I didn't write them down I
mean I got them in exact order
so yes Medicare does pay less than
private insurers now the question you
might want to ask yourself is why do
private if this is the private insurers
outside of Medicare not within within
Medicare private insurers as I said
shadow price Medicare but in the
employer market private insurers pay a
great deal more than Medicare and the
individual market they pay more than
Medicare why is that and that's partly
because of the monopolies that have
developed especially at the local level
throughout the healthcare system
this is a point that I make in the
there's a new edition of the social
transformation of American medicine it's
a book that came out in 1982 this one
that just came out in June a new updated
edition and one of the big themes of the
additional material that I've added it
has to do with the growing consolidation
of control in local health care markets
the rise of large hospital systems often
with what are called must-have
institutions must have from the point of
view of insurers and employers and those
powerful healthcare systems have been
able to drive up the payment rates to
much higher levels than Medicare pays
the industry tells the story that it's
cost shifting because it doesn't get as
much as Medicare it has to get more from
private insurers but if that were the
case then those hospitals that had more
Medicare beneficiaries would have
especially high rates it's actually not
true
where Medicare is as important private
insurers also pay less the evidence
actually is contrary to what David
suggested that Medicare has helped
instill costs discipline and that
expanding Medicare making it available
to other people would help create a
greater disciplining cost in the
American healthcare system is the way
the way David described the history it
was only Medicare that was driving the
economic evolution of the American
healthcare system that's just not so the
employer based private insurance system
has been a very powerful influence on
the way on the way our system has
evolved and it has been especially weak
in controlling costs insurers have been
able to pass those costs on to employers
employers have been able to cast
those costs on to workers and employees
and their families don't know that money
is deducted from paychecks before they
ever see them they have very little way
of acting effectively in the marketplace
so I I believe that extending a public
option would have an important role as a
countervailing force to this
concentrated power that is developed in
the healthcare industry thank you Paul
five minutes for you David for your
rebuttal thank you I I didn't forget
that Medicare Advantage exists I'm
describing it as a marketplace is pretty
remarkable Medicare sets the rates that
reimburses describes the policies fairly
in-depth and in fact I think Medicare
Advantage is just a wonderful example of
how extraordinarily corrupting the
incentives of Medicare is the theory was
let's create an option for seniors
within Medicare so Medicare Advantage
pays slightly more than their fee for
service number it depends it's changed
from year to year and quickly what
insurers discovered is the key was to
define your benefits so that you got the
healthy of Medicare patients and made
more money not in sound like much of a
marketplace to me the argument stays
right I just cannot accept that the
primary customer of our Hospital sector
that allows a 65 percent capacity
industry to operate at a seven or eight
percent market is great for controlling
costs I get it the prices look LUP but
any of us who have actually been in
business know that the price is low is
not the same as genuine dust real
discipline look at the big numbers and
in fact let's look at the big numbers
you know the there's probably no
metaphor used more than the boiling
frogs metaphor and and professor stars
right seniors love Medicare because the
alternative is too frightening but let's
pretend somehow that a 65 year old when
Medicare was passed was alive today
here's what that senior would have found
that the share of healthcare they pay
out-of-pocket had gone from 10% of their
income to 18% of their income that in an
average year they spend $3,500 of their
own money on health care that Medicare
premiums and cost-sharing take 25% of
their social security benefit now just
like every other health care program
we've had when Medicare was passed it
was going to solve all these problems
it's gonna cost take care of cost
control give you access and all the rest
the problem of health costs for seniors
now he is meaningfully greater than it
was in 1965 they don't know it because
they weren't alive in 1960 or they
weren't seniors in 1965 and this is how
the entire health care system has
developed this is how we got to 18% of
GDP all incremental helpful ideas like
the public option all things that are
really gonna make it cheaper and really
make it universal I believe in universal
access to care but the difficulty with
the things like Medicare is because
there are political programs that
disguise their true working they wind up
shifting ever more of our dollars from
everything else to health care and we
are poorer for it health care is the
10th most important factor in health
measured by almost anything you name it
income education safety of your
community marital status having a job
all of these things have a lot more to
do with your health and as the United
States has uniquely gone to 18% of GDP
on health care we have less for that
David Brooks referred to the US
government as an emerging healthcare
state we can afford nothing else if you
believe that this latest great idea to
solve the problem the seventh or eighth
we'll have any different result than the
others then I appreciate your optimism I
wish I shared it because I believe in
universal coverage over time like in
anything else that matters the only way
we will make sure everybody has afford
health care is to do something
meaningful about prices there's no
financial engineering that turns
expensive health care into affordable
health care it's just the moves the
money around and the only way we're
gonna have health care that has the
impact on our lives close to the amount
of money we're spending is for it to be
good and while we focus in the political
arena all the time on people who don't
have access and all the rest the amazing
thing is the fatality rate because of
excess undisciplined care in the United
States far exceeds the fatality rate for
people who don't get care it's not part
of the discussion it's not as much fun
it's much more fun to talk about access
and be you know this wonderful giving
person guaranteeing care to everybody
but what has it wrong what do we really
have and as we think about health care
down the road what is it that we want
our health care system to the market
thank you David
yeah all right in this in this part of
the debate each side gets to ask each
other two questions Paul would you be
willing to go first and ask David a
question so David I was stunned at the
end when you said you were in favor of
universal coverage I'm not quite sure
how you plan to get there that might be
the first question but let me also ask
you this you seem to be suggesting that
because of the stark character of your
criticism that seniors should just go
cold turkey on Medicare well I used to
really you say Medicare is is killing
people basically you say the health care
system is killing people that people who
don't get treated or better off than
people who get treated that well
actually you guys think actually they
could roll back the tape I said there
were fewer there were fewer fewer people
who okay well it it it sounded to me
very similar to a doctor
in the 19th century known as therapeutic
nihilism which suggests and actually if
you go back to the 1830s 1840s
therapeutic nihilism was justified
because the medicine and that they
probably did kill more people but you've
got a kind of updated therapeutic
nihilism you you you you've got the view
that the health care system is so
terrible I'm putting money into it is so
destructive that Americans would be
better off if they just didn't have it
we should go back to 4% of GDP instead
of what we're spending now that would
mean closing down a lot of hospitals and
letting go a lot of doctors and nurses
okay is that what you mean okay that's
the question David please respond to the
question yeah so uh no I'm not calling
for abolishing health care what I'm
calling for although we should abolish
the term but that's a different subject
because there's talking about ten or
fifteen thousand different services
consumed in different ways in different
parts of our life as if it's one thing
has probably cost this country more
value than almost any other political
era we make but but but let me deal with
what I think you misunderstood about
what I was saying so my focus is on the
incentives to practice health care in
the system we build I you know as a as a
history major I respect the history but
the reality is there isn't a health care
industry until well into the 20th
century in the sense of providing any
value and worth argument over the issue
is the incentives and how we buy health
care how does an industry respond and my
argument is that the unique American
politics and the unique American
political structure has so warped the
incentives in our public programs the
damage caused by excess care
undisciplined care lack of the normal
responsiveness to consumer need look 75
percent of the care dollars in this
country are spent on chronic conditions
and yet we have an industry that
packages almost everything on a
fee-for-service basis and all the
experiments that met
Kara's done to do something different
have wound up creating those very
monopolies you talked about I am focused
on how care is actually delivered for
our 18% of GDP so I am in favor of
universal coverage I have argued written
a book that if we can understand that
what we're trying to ensure against this
catastrophe and not warp an entire
industry by trying to include everything
in this insurance rubric we will have
something that closer serves our social
needs and it's better balanced in
society with everything else and let me
just make one last point one of the key
things I talk about when I'm talking
about the island is the fact that there
can be no trade off between what we
spend on health care in any of our other
goals as a society or as individuals
putting everything into an insurance
system creating Medicare as an
entitlement and Medicaid is kind of a
part entitlement is absolutely unique in
the world no one else has done that
where there's no leakage once it's
healthcare it's gonna get spent on
health care it's not as an employer it's
not surprising to me that the cost of
health care goes up every year even
though people get healthier because
that's not what drives it what drives it
as these industrial factors and so when
I hear yet another idea for doing more
of the same I can't help but notice that
Medicare didn't solve seniors financing
problem and health care and neither did
Medicaid the Affordable Care Act has
extended coverage but it's almost
useless because the deductibles and I
also noticed that we've maintained
different health care systems for
seniors for poor people for veterans and
all the rest and I don't think that's
just about money it's you guys okay I
David a question for Paul so when I
started getting interested in care as an
employer I looked at what a young person
is gonna contribute into our health care
system over her lifetime and so I took
literally somebody starting out for us
and I looked at all of the insurance
premiums that would be paid in her name
over a lifetime her Medicare premiums
the Medicare taxes because as you know
we now subsidized Medicare
normos leader general tax revenues the
amount she'd spent on Medicaid
everything for the safety net and for
health care and I made a couple of
important assumptions one is that you
know she lives through life what used to
roughly be the average got married had
kids
III assumed she never gets it may
meaningfully say and I assume she never
got rich when she was solidly middle
class or whole life so using a zero
percent growth rate the number was 1.2
million dollars that's what we're asking
a twenty three-year-old today to have
put out of her income into our health
care system to maintain this safety net
and to maintain this extraordinarily
centralized don't care how do you
justify that to her
what do you've taken that number that
number is kind of meaningless since
you're projecting somebody's but you
know I we do spend a lot on health care
in the United States it's eighteen
percent of the economy it's eighteen
percent of national income in the eighty
percent of gross domestic product of
course those numbers are all going to
look big and what surprises me about
your approach is that if you wanted to
spend a lot less on health care you'd
look at the countries that spend a lot
less on health care
do you other rich countries I mean not
the poor ones the other rich countries
meaning Britain France Sweden the almost
mostly European countries and they have
a lot more governmental control of
health care than we do they they they
they regulate they control prices they
take control employment in the health
care sector so someone who started out
with your view that we're just spending
so much more of our economy than we
should be on health care it seems to me
on the basis of the comparative evidence
would be drawn to exactly the opposite
conclusion that we need a lot more
government control not less because
really they're mean you may have your
Singapore case but otherwise you don't
have you don't got you know you don't
have a lot of evidence to support your
view which I you know again it's really
kind of hard
for me to decipher what would your view
ultimately is that if there were if
government pulled out that the market
would operate in such a way that we
would be back at a much lower level of
expenditure well no one could we just
okay can we treat that as our questions
to each other I mean so Singapore maybe
the most government controlled health
care system on earth but it uses
free-market principles to exercise that
control this is not for me an ideology
of whether it's government or not
government that's irrelevant and the
examples of other countries are
irrelevant because none of them have our
political system so nobody has a
Medicare program the equivalent of a
Medicare program that has run for
insiders the degree by which special
interests set prices determine service
prevent regulation and Medicare is
absolutely unique on earth and I
remember once in a debate like this
someone's saying we should have Sweden
system we don't have Sweden system of
government what we have is a system of
government in which you're always
allowed to lobby everything and to look
at Medicare and it's why I brought it up
and not understand the extent to which I
mean I would say this to you you're
someone who's been so conscious of
special interests over your career who
do you think runs Medicare this fantasy
that there's some Medicare makes no
decisions on appropriateness when
Medicare decided that men over 75
shouldn't have PSA tests since not
paying for them after them still do when
Medicare decided people shouldn't have
spinal fusions didn't stop paying for it
industry wouldn't let it let's talk
about America because America's problem
is unique okay you you blew your second
question Paul you have a second question
hey okay okay if America's political
system is so utterly wrought with
special interests how do you propose
working with the institutions that we
have
how do you propose thank you to change
it I mean it really sounds so that's
that's really don't like dirty
scientistic no I hate to see that no I
mean I'm probably the only real optimist
in the room because you know almost all
of our ideas about healthcare are 70 80
years old the NHS is 70 years old this
is an absolute dinosaur health care is
changing radically when the national
health system started and we decided
insurance should run everything in
health care it was a different thing
health care was rare and major in ER
urgent and the integration and our lives
from birth to death didn't exist so when
health care when the big national
healthcare systems were created almost
all care was therapy wasn't chronic
condition which is the bulk of what we
do now it's already changed in two
generations with a system that hasn't
changed with it going forward we look at
a world of personalized cures something
the system hasn't done since we had
infectious diseases what we need to
understand is healthcare is a dynamic
industry and the idea that these
seventy-year-old systems are what should
guide us strikes me as absurd health
care health care is an essential like
food and we used to insist that food be
divvied out by the high priests it was
just too important to be left to the
markets the further you are from that
the more food your people have we need
to reintegrate healthcare which means we
want a safety net for urgent things in
healthcare let's have one let's have an
insurance system for catastrophes but if
each one of my employees is going to put
a million dollars into healthcare over
her lifetime without her getting rich
her single biggest expensive that's what
we have today before this newest plan
today imposed on our young people then
we need to stop and we need to think
about here's what we want a safety net
for here's where we want to bring in
some market forces competition here's
where we want consumers to be empowered
you don't need a single idea to solve an
industry with tens of thousands of goods
and services it's okay to have a hybrid
and instead what we've done is
look for a magic bullet and in anything
complex a magic bullet is a foolish
exercise and we are not the only country
suffering under very rapidly increasing
health care costs all of those other
systems are thank you David okay
questions from the audience now line up
please and I don't quite see you but is
there somebody up at the mic who is
going to ask the first question the
microphone is back there are there
people lining up and please phrase your
question as a question and avoid
speechifying first questioner at the mic
please ask a question when Obamacare was
launched I recall that the government
funded coops which were public insurance
plans a public option sort of to compete
with the private insurance companies and
my understanding is most of them have
imploded and failed I unfortunately was
in one of them first Republic here in
New York State which failed so since
we've already done a program with the
government funding insurance companies
to compete with private insurance
companies why would this new idea work
yeah well the that that provision for
coops was actually a substitute for a
public option wasn't the public option
it was a public option that would have
been operated by Medicare would not have
had the problems that those little
undercapitalized coops had so one of the
difficulties that many of them had is
that they they were they had too little
capital to sustain themselves in the
marketplace
one of the whenever you have a new
market this was true actually in the
care market back when it was beginning
when Medicare it would private Medicare
plans were beginning it's very difficult
to estimate risks there's a lot of
turbulence in markets before they settle
down and many of those coops as I said
they had relatively little capital they
they made mistakes estimating their
costs and they got into trouble and also
the Republican Congress withdrew a lot
of the funding for them so this is not a
question of simple natural immortality
there was an active effort to kill them
to shut them down by the Republican
Congress that helped snuff out the the
survivors so that's a you know that's
that's a poor example of of a public
option has nothing to do with with the
Medicare proposal well I think you know
the questioner makes an excellent point
missing just one thing I think you're
wrong but most of them went out of
business I think they all went out of
business I don't think there's a single
winner that survived a there are there's
still a couple of them yeah it's
essentially all of them and in it what's
the point I made in the first debate
there for the first part of this debate
is that the public option is fantasy
right there's no way to price this this
is all about the government increasing
its role and insurance and by the way
that's a reasonable argument to have but
the idea that the government is going to
suddenly act like a competitive
insurance company or that in telling
Medicare Advantage providers that has
somehow running a marketplace is absurd
these coops were intended to demonstrate
in a real marketplace how a public
option would work and here's how it
works the government is going to have to
be willing to absorb the kind of losses
these cooperatives were unable to absorb
look again I think you could have sent a
history of what happened okay well is
they have actually all thriving I'm
wrong no no no the idea you know it came
from people who were opposed to the
public yes but we are nevertheless we
nevertheless have grown since Medicare
started
from five and a half percent of GDP to
eighteen and every single policy has
saved money and at some point we have to
be genuinely serious these are not the
right ways to build a 21st century
health care system
these are 20th century ideas that have
failed and the idea that the only way to
fix them is to endlessly do more
it's an unappealing one the reality is
health care is insanely expensive for
the average American it's short or not
in short next question yes I'm as a
lead-in to my question I'm going one
rate raised the issue of doctor owned
hospitals and how they are treated under
Obamacare which is that there was a
strict limit put on the expansion of
doctor owned hospitals unless they
refused to accept make their Medicaid
and and doctor own hospitals have been
controversial within the hospital
industry let's say because of the
supposed adverse selection problem they
tend to attract richer and and and
healthier patients but they're also more
innovative and they have much higher
satisfaction ratings than the
traditional for-profit and so-called
nonprofit hospitals but but I just want
to use that as an example of how when
there's additional regulatory burden put
into the system or when there's an
expansion of government involvement in
setting policy that inevitably responds
to the there's regulatory capture I mean
there's that they essentially responded
to the for-profit nonprofit very
powerful lobbies at to squelch the
competition from dr. on hospitals so why
would that not simply be put on
overdrive under under going from say
where we are today
48% public public spend is government or
of healthcare spending government going
to say 70 like it is in Canada why would
that not further squelch innovation and
competition in the system then compared
to what we have today I want to tell you
the question I'm afraid I really don't
know anything about dr. on hospitals I
think this was this was a question of
self dealing and conflict of interest
and that's why limitations were put on
it but it's really not a subject I know
a great deal about okay well I do know
something about this subject because the
question is exactly right dr. on
hospitals been killed almost everywhere
including at CMS because they compete
with general hospitals and the argument
was oh my god look at the conflict of
interest but I think the general point
is a more important one I'm on the board
of something called the Leapfrog Group
which presses for transparency in
hospital safety our opponent is almost
always CMS which runs Medicare CMS makes
the argument that too much transparency
is unfair to hospitals now you can
imagine if the FAA said announcing which
planes crash or unfair to Airlines the
degree of Industry capture in the way
health care policy actually happens in
this country is beyond anyone's
imagination and weirdly enough it so
distorts the way health care is
delivered that this bizarre superficial
external conversation we have about how
to pay for it ignores how the way we're
paying for it is creating this reality I
could spend the rest of the night
talking about ways in which CMS and the
government have prevented competition I
mean look at accountable care
organizations their legal monopolies to
save money these people actually believe
that if you give someone monopoly status
they will be more efficient and somehow
passed those savings on and 51 years of
being wrong won't convince them it's
just about to work my fundamental
problem is this
I believe in strong government
regulation of the health care system
it's dangerous it's unsafe there are
constantly new technologies and it
doesn't enormous
good you got a choice the government can
be the industry's partner or regulator
it's not gonna be both next question
yeah so thanks a lot for for making
arguments concerning the efficacy of
Medicare but I have a more fundamental
question what is so special about health
care that we can justify a government
program to actually use tax dollars in
order to subsidize this because I
understand health care there are
benefits to having health care but there
are benefits other things like a
girlfriend loves Chanel bags and the
fact that you know she's getting taxed
for like Medicare means there's just
less money to spend on Chanel bags why
don't we like it a public option for
like you know expensive handbag right I
mean if you ask her she might even say
like you know she cares about the Chanel
bag right now cause she's pretty healthy
so let David David you want to respond
to that well I'm a Miss Carr you
actually can get Chanel bags under some
Medicare Advantage programs but but I
think you know look the reality is we
have a political system to determine
social priorities a lot of us do believe
that there are things about health care
that is unique including as a as a
service that it's not it's not gonna
work fully with a market like others I
believe that I don't that's true of all
of health care but I think it's true of
a lot of health care we don't want and
we are wealthy enough country that
everybody in this country should be able
to afford high-quality health care and
there are ways society can help do that
the bigger part of your question though
is really crucial which is the
fundamental reason we and many other
countries on earth have decided that
health care is the single most important
thing the government should spend money
on is probably an old one and probably a
political one and let's face it if
you're a politician it is a lot easier
to be arguing about access to health
care and look at what I am giving you
then to address the nine more important
things that contribute to your health
social structure of marital structure
community safety education lifestyles
those are difficult now it's harder for
us to address those without the money so
when I see Singapore paying 4% and think
they've got
96% to spend on anything else I like
that you want to be spent pool well well
we are a democracy people have voted and
I think they've voted in reflection of
the fact that if the private market were
just left to itself there would be
millions of people who would be unable
to afford care that was indeed the
situation facing many millions of
seniors before Medicare was established
that's why there was the demand for it
the private insurance market was not
interested in insuring older people who
were bad risks and so so Americans
responded to that reality and the the
popularity of the Medicare reflects the
fact that Americans are are getting some
protection that they wouldn't otherwise
have all right next question
thanks both for a great debate I wanted
to get a little more elaboration on the
idea of a caste erotic care system I've
read meg McArdle's proposal on an
insurer of last resort system which
essentially would make health care or
government-sponsored health care almost
a female like system for health care
where individuals pay maybe 15 to 20% of
their adjusted gross income if they have
health care expenditures that go over
that amount the government pays a
hundred percent of whatever those fees
may be and that if you're on the poverty
line or something to be special
exemptions and it'll be up to the
individual then to decide within a
private marketplace I'm going to insure
myself to take care of that potential 15
to 20 percent accident or emergency that
I have that would cause me to go to the
hospital and have a major procedure done
would love both of your thoughts on if
that system could work well what the
pros and cons would be and so forth
so can I respond to this because I
really think there's there's something a
lot of a lot of people may not may not
get about this 10% of the population in
any given year accounts for about
two-thirds of all of health care costs
there's another 50% of the population
that only generate 3% of health care
costs why is that because sick people
generate very sick people generate most
of the costs and in any given year yeah
a lot of people healthy and they don't
have any cost at all
so I maybe I didn't understand this
proposal correctly but if it's that
everybody would pay 15% and then the
government would pick up all the costs
over gee that doesn't sound like a good
deal to me the the one of the
difficulties that we have in controlling
health care costs is that the usual
deterrence that people are paying
out-of-pocket doesn't work when people
have these very high costs that are over
their deductibles even if they're in a
high deductible plan and so there's very
little sensitivity to cost from the
consumers side and there's no
sensitivity from the providers side and
that's effectively why you need some
kind of regulation it's because of this
concentration of health costs got
concentration of total expenditures and
because of the lack of the normal
mechanisms that work in the market to
control costs so when I said that a
remarkable amount of our health care
system was based on incredibly old ideas
I was referring directly to what
Professor Starr just said so he's
absolutely right
10% of our population uses 65% of
healthcare costs in any given year so if
you plan on living one year that really
matters but by the way that is less
concentration than in any other
expensive good and service in any given
year less than 10% of the population
buys a hundred percent of the cars 100
percent of refrigerators as a hundred
percent of the marriages divorces you
name it
this idea people have been saying in
health care for 70 years without
thinking of what in any given year means
in any given year 10% of the population
uses all of the college education so
what we live 80 years this is a question
of finance that has been the argument
for having this massively complex
insanely expensive ridiculously
distortive system of insurance pay for
everything that argument and it has no
reference to anything else in human life
it's the island of health care you go to
a health care conference you say what
professor start just said everybody nods
but nobody says what isn't that true of
these true them what the end of
ridiculous let me finish the point we
know that you're going to use a lot of
health care certain times of your life
towards the end at the beginning we know
that your health care demand is going to
very enormous Lee over the years in
between we have tons of things like that
health care is unique in that being the
argument for creating this thing that
adds four or five hundred billion
dollars of administrative costs a year
to you that argument and it makes no
sense if you've ever been in any
industry other than health care did you
respond Paul today yeah because that's
not really the point that I was making
the point is that when you have that
concentration of expenditures the normal
mechanisms that people have counted on
and that are that they're counting on
even with high deductible plans with
your catastrophic coverage that they
don't work they don't work in
controlling the cost that's a complete
misunderstanding and and and I must have
no I hear this all the time from
traditional health care experts you know
every argument you have in health care
is if it doesn't work for everybody all
the time it can't work right no nothing
else in our economy works like that
right some things work for some people
sometimes other people we agree like
diversity of services diversity in the
way you charge alternatives for how
something is delivered health care every
argument is oh my god a consumer-driven
system can't work because if somebody's
hit by a bus
they're too unconscious to shop
Hospital again but that is not the
argument being made the argument being
made is we are now spending a million
dollars per person per life on health
care we can take a reasonable amount of
that million dollars since most of it
will be spent on chronic conditions and
we can finance it in any number of ways
that makes that person a consumer so
like we do without everything else they
did David let's be specific your favor
of catastrophic coverage is that right
so that's that's high deductible
coverage yeah so what happens when
people hit the deductible when they're
when they've gone over the deductible
how do you control the costs how do you
control the costs that's right
they're now fully covered okay it's over
the deductible they're not it's not
coming out of their pocket you know how
Singapore doesn't well it's that's a
that's what you do you know I'm sorry
that Singapore does it but that's a
government controlled system right
here's how Singapore does it so
Singapore as you know has at every
single level of health spending the
individual is the actual customer you
know in our system the insurer and CMS
is the customer you're not actually the
guy who buys the service they do so
you're always the customer and there is
literally nothing for which you don't
have to write some cheque even tiny
which makes you sensitive the total
amount but if your concern is that a
system of catastrophic only insurance in
the case of catastrophes is going to
lead to massive inflation then let me
suggest this since massive catastrophes
are somewhere in the depending on how
you measure it 15 to 20 percent of
health care let me run my system for the
other 80% you do whatever you want with
the other 20% and we'll take advantage
of the fact I don't know if you've ever
had a tire blowout on a highway but if
you have a tire blowout on a highway
when the tow truck comes he doesn't ask
to look at your net worth statement he
charges you more than if you just
shopped for a replacement tire but it's
governed by the fact that there's a
normal tire market you're screwed when
that happens but he ain't taking your
net worth
we have a healthcare system where the
argument that oh my you know Medicare's
most expensive patient cost two and a
half million bucks it reported five
years ago that sound like a lot of money
does right except for the fact when you
think about we spend a million dollars
on average on every person over a
lifetime now it's only to when I have
times are we really gonna let that one
person that one extreme thing not
financed a million dollars sensibly
this isn't 1965 anymore we're not
talking about getting a few hundred
dollars from each of the people in the
room and saying don't worry we'll take
care of the rest
we're taking a million dollars from each
of the people in this room I'm not
following you in your high deductible
catastrophic coverage right what
controls the costs in cases that go over
the deductible the insurer just like you
do now what do you think controls it now
all insurance an insurer a pace a price
to a pay
so the insurer can say no the insurer
can say well is it I mean are you giving
the patient doctor any control at all at
that point I don't I don't see a patient
doctor who has control how are you
proposing to control costs in the
high-cost cases that generate a very
large proportion of our so what I'm
willing to say is for well it does not
generate right that's that's no longer
true so that is note by the way your 10%
in 65 was 10% in 80 as recently as 10
years ago
so that's changing meaningfully but give
me the most recent figures but I can yes
no no you're right that comes down
concentration comes down every year
that's my point
and yours too so what are yours what I'm
willing to say is in those worst cases
keep the current system if you must but
build a market for the rest that's not
so that you actually look what we have
you you go see a physician it's insured
and it's several hundred dollars and the
insurer is going to get several tenth or
the physician is going to get several
tens of dollars it's an absurd system
adding cost to every transaction you
know something you're knocking on an
open door
millions of people have high deductible
coverage today if that's what you want
45 million you you know it already
exists no but honestly and and by the
way if you look at and what people think
about it
they hate it well but be honest you go
to a system where you say to somebody
you have a $500 deductible today and
then next year you say over $1,500 so
the if the response was enthusiasm I'd
be stunned the the purpose of high
deductible plans and genuine
catastrophic insurance which as you know
is different from high deductible
insurance we have high deductible I talk
about catastrophic is to say to people
the average family insured policy in
America now cost $20,000 a year $20,000
now you may not see it the government's
figured out lots of ways to take it from
this pocket in that pocket and over here
well you didn't see that it's $20,000 a
year for your family
$20,000 now unless you're wealthy there
is your janitor it's $20,000 so unless
you're wealthy that's a lot of money so
the way catastrophic coverage works
which is not what we had under the
affordable care act is Janelle was
explicitly prohibited is to say tell you
what take a twenty thousand dollar
deductible and insurance it's gonna cost
you six seven thousand dollars but
thirteen thousand dollars away a year
you're a year and a half away from
paying for that deductible that's how
catastrophic insurance works it's not
just hey we increase your deductible and
you're paying which you are now it's
we're increasing your deductible enough
that we're freeing up the absurd amount
of money we put into the expense and
complexity of an insurance system
now here's what we've done in this
country every year it gets more
expensive and every year intervention is
ever more necessary so you can afford it
and here's the latest idea a public
option is going to make it cheaper for
you just like Medicare made it cheaper
for seniors but the only way Medicare
made it cheaper for seniors is they're
not still here to compare you compare it
to no Medicare not to life before
Medicare next question
no it's what that's different that's
actually socialized medicine the the
Veterans Administration is like the
national service it's different for
Medicare
there has to be the last question of the
evening thank you for the question Paul
you might well that you're talking about
a different idea you're talking about a
system in which the federal government
actually owns the hospitals it employs
the doctors as I said at the beginning
and really I think you ought to know
this I mean Medicare is totally
different it's an insurance system
Medicare does not all in the hospital's
it does not employ the doctors and in
fact it has a system where there's both
a public plan and there are private
alternatives very different from from
from the veteran system actually the
very first the very first thing I ever
wrote about health care was a critique
of the veteran's health care system I
don't need to go back through that but
really I mean it's just it's two
different things we unfortunately have
to close the qat part of the evening
thank you for your questions we're going
to the summary portion of the evening
and you want to think about how you vote
on the resolution Paul you have five
minutes to sum up you can go up to the
podium and do that and that will be
followed by David's summation five
minutes take it away poll well I have
tried to make the case for making
available to Americans a Medicare white
plan as an alternative that they can buy
I'm specifically talking about people
who buy health insurance on their own
these are the people in the individual
and to some extent the small group
market those markets have functioned
very inefficiently and although the
Affordable Care Act has enabled millions
of people in that position to be able to
afford insurance the options available
to them in many parts of the country
have in fact been very limited those
especially are true in rural areas and
the south and the west these are regions
where there's very
competition and there's an additional
problem of competition that I mentioned
in many big cities in many urban areas
where how some hospital systems have
achieved overwhelming power where
there's been a growth of monopoly power
and that has affected prices in those
metropolitan areas it's driven up
insurance costs and the what we need in
both in the rural areas and the south
these areas where there is often only
one insurer or maybe no insurers
we need a Medicare to come in I
suggested that we should have both
public Medicare and the private Medicare
Advantage plans offered in those areas
to stimulate competition and I'd like to
see a Medicare plan a lot like plan in
many of the urban areas where there is
monopoly power to be able to have some
kind of a countervailing power from a
public plan so these are ideas not for a
radical overturning of the healthcare
system it's not a single-payer plan that
I'm talking about it's using Medicare as
a way to provide more options more
choices for people and to countervail
some of the power that's accumulated in
the private marketplace I mean this is
the reality a reality which I really
think David ought to address the reality
of monopoly power that has developed in
health care in provider markets also in
insurer markets and that has distorted
what we can expect the market left to
itself to be able to do
thank you Paul five minutes for you
David to do us summation well let me
start with what Paul said because he and
I are in complete agreement of the
dangers of monopoly power among
healthcare providers
what he doesn't recognize is that that
monopoly power has been encouraged by
the major buyer of health care the US
government there's a narrative in health
care that we're used to which is after
the war developed countries recognized
health care as an essential right to all
citizens and except in the United States
began addressing that need through a
variety of different forms there's
actually quite a mix of health care
systems in the developed world but what
they have in common is they have an
enormous amount of government
intervention in the markets in America
this narrative goes like this only the
United States because of special
interest and because of our unique
politics hasn't made this commitment but
it's coming it's progress it's the
future what if that narrative is
backwards what if the fact that these
ideas were created when health care was
fundamentally a one-size-fits-all
industry no longer makes sense what if
the reason that every developed country
on earth has difficulty paying for ever
growing healthcare and despite what's
often monopolies buying power can't
control prices reflects the obvious
mismatch between how health care is paid
for and how we need it what if this idea
that everything in health care is like a
building burning down an insurance claim
is absurd on its face in sentences us to
a system that very well serves
bureaucrats GMs large insurance
companies and very poorly serves the
customer
there's 315 million stories of why our
health care system doesn't work some of
them are about cost and access a lot of
them is about absolutely primitive use
of electronic health records despite the
fact that Medicare gave forty five
billion dollars to create electronic
health records some of it's about the
absolute confusion of going from
specialist to specialist or hospital to
another service some of it is about poor
care accident error injury death
Medicare itself says one out of every
seven Medicare beneficiaries who goes
into an Hospital
has a adverse health effect because of
an error what if we have an
undisciplined wasteful expensive complex
untransparent health care system not
because we don't have access but because
in fact the force is intended to
discipline it don't what if the
narrative is completely backwards what
if the future of healthcare is much more
like other things actually using
information technology to make it work
better for the individuals as we've
moved from you have breast cancer to you
have you cancer is this healthcare
system going to be able to adapt is this
healthcare system going to work in an
error of cures while we've been going on
this historic narrative to be like
Europe to have real coverage we've
missed the numbers we've missed the fact
that the average American young
personnel will be saddled with over a
million dollars of healthcare costs in
great part because we built this massive
system to protect her from healthcare
costs we've missed the fact that the
average senior now pays more
out-of-pocket now than the average
senior did in 1965 we've missed the fact
that the trillion and a half dollars the
United States government governments
including the states are going to spend
on health care this year could instead
be a $20,000 grant to half of American
households every year with a sixty
thousand dollar median income and all of
the issues we have the island of health
care prevents us from even thinking
about that even thinking about the
transformation we could have look there
are many people on one side of this
debate who are in love with the National
Health Service apparently they haven't
followed very clearly what it's been
dealing with in the last couple years a
seventy-year-old model you know a lot of
other great ways of running
technologically complex ever-changing
dynamic industries there's 70 years old
I don't everything else got disrupted in
the last 25 years the first rule the
first rule of getting out of a hole is
to stop
digging tonight's proposition is another
shovel full thank you very much okay now
please look back at your cell phones the
US government should offer a Medicare
life plan that would be available to all
Americans buying health insurance Kate
to share Bo would you come up to the
stage again because so we're gonna have
the final voting Kate are you there
there you are okay yeah yeah yeah behind
you hope she's okay all right okay while
you're considering the vote kate is
doing the tally and also I want again to
invite both Paul Starr and David to
stick around for the party to discuss
these issues further to please buy a
drink of the bar or to have some water
and discuss these issues and then as
well Larry will be our government our
candidate for governor will be at his
table ready to discuss those issues with
you as well and so please stick around
for the party
okay well and what what well I'm it
would give me your judgment I will
certainly give another minute for people
ups to deliberate on the voting and
we'll see who wins the chassis roll all
right so I want to see the results okay
all right
oops yeah okay it the the the yes vote
was 21 percent in favor before the
voting began the yes vote went down to
14 percent after the voting so the yes
vote lost seven points the no vote was
at 47% and it went up to 77 percent so
David gold hill wins the to zero
the noes have it thank you to Paul stock
back in to Jamie Gold Hill
please stick around for the party